Okay. Good morning. We are live. Hi.
Where have I been the last couple days?
Well,
we've been doing some really, really
stupid work.
And um
let's put it this way, right?
I got Puffer Lib down to what 4,000
lines.
And uh I looked at the code and I went,
if I spent the next couple weeks working
on cleaning this up, I could probably
only cut another 300 lines off of this.
And I wasn't happy with the way it
looked. There was a whole bunch of bloat
coming from torch. whole bunch of fancy
things that you really couldn't touch
too much that could just break. I wasn't
happy with it. And then I thought, you
know, Torch really isn't doing that much
for us here.
Um, it's quite a bit of refactoring work
in order to get this into something
without torch just the way it's set up.
But it's really stupid work. I can
probably do a lot of this with Claude as
long as I'm actually checking [ __ ] and
like, you know, writing tests and all
that. Uh, it's just going to take me an
extra, you know, 10 15 hours of work
this week. So, I figured I'd put in the
work and, uh, I've worked till 10 or 11
the last couple of evenings, put in
quite a few extra hours.
And let me show you the result of this.
First of all,
boom. Fast build caches, but also 5
seconds or so. Fresh,
right? So, look at this. One, two,
three, four, five. All right. A little
longer. Six. Yeah, six seconds.
Whatever.
So you'll see here there's no torch
anywhere in here, right? No torch
and we are able to train this thing in
like 67 seconds. This is on my local
machine with the stream running and
everything.
And look at the score. 859.978.
Remember this number. I'm going to run
it again.
Exact same number. That's right. We have
fully deterministic training, fully
reproducible,
all in static memory. No dynamic memory
allocations during training.
No torch.
Pretty good, right?
Pretty good.
And if we look at the latest word count,
you can take off about 900 lines. Was it
800 some odd lines? Yeah, for Puffernet.
So about 5,000 lines of code is what we
have for everything.
If we can get this to this number to
4,000, I will be much happier.
I think that is the major goal.
I really want to start cleaning this up
manually. I think unfortunately there's
still going to have to be more some more
claw bullshitting, but we're going to
start this stream today just by spending
a little bit of time looking over the
code um and kind of getting a picture of
stuff.
First of all, this file is about the
same length as it was before.
Um,
we can get rid of these. Actually,
We have
puff slice.
Yeah. So, we're probably going to want
to set up some basic
uh a little bit better of a tenser.
Hey, there. You said no torch. No torch.
This is raw cuda.
Isn't that cool?
It just got to the point where we ship A
thesis at like Torch was doing so little
for us anyways. It was like causing more
problems than it was worth. We have an
extra thousand lines of code at the
moment for a bunch of bullshitty little
custom kernels. But I think we're going
to ultimately get the code around the
same size it was before with no torch
and faster and static memory and fully
reproducible and a bunch of other nice
things. And honestly, I think this is
going to be easier to think about
because now all you have to do is you
think about CUDA. So all the stuff that
Torch brings in, all the [ __ ] of
Torch, you don't have to think about at
all.
And it will still be Torch compatible.
Like if you want, you can just take any
of our stuff from here. You can just
call like from blob on the memory and
you can just run torch ops. I almost
don't even want to call the CL like call
this a tensor cuz it's just memory.
Hi user.
Fully reproducible action distribution.
Yep. Everything is fully reproduc. I'm
still banned on YouTube. Really?
I remember unbanning you on YouTube cuz
that was a misclick. Let me go check.
Let me go check.
I was almost positive I had like gone in
and unbanned you on that.
Let me figure out where your thing is so
I can unban you. That was just I swear
that was a misclick, man. Okay.
Settings.
Play back.
Unban you
Hi. I'm trying to get Oh,
wait. Here. This one just didn't show
up. Oh, no. There it is. I'm trying to
get into reinforcement learning as a
hobby. I'm a software developer with a
few years experience. How would you
recommend getting into it? You are the
ideal target audience for the exact
content I have already written. So it
will actually be very easy for you.
Let me show you. Why do I have 20 plus
notifications?
What in the heck?
Oh, this
ah this got some cool attention. That's
nice.
That's very nice.
if you're brand new to programming uh or
to ML you can start here but otherwise
follow this article
this exact thing
it'll walk you through step by step
building a couple of M's
and uh this like will be enough to
already be contributing productively to
the science
And why does YouTube make it so freaking
complicated to find anything?
It's not here.
Distributed computing. Yeah, it'll work.
Debbie, um, it's just NCCL.
I actually don't know with the new
version if there's additional setup, but
it's literally one all reduce op. It's
really simple.
Hang on. Now I have to go watch a video
in order to figure out
I swear. What is wrong with Google
engineer sometimes?
Oh, here it is.
Community moderation.
Okay. Which one of these is you?
Is it Lance?
No problem. If you want to figure out
and test the all reduced stuff once I
have this cleaned up, you're more than
welcome to. Uh we definitely need to
have that working. But look how simple
it is.
All right. This is it.
There you go. That's null reduce.
Not hard.
We actually had that working with torch
even before I ported it because it was
too annoying to figure out how to use
torches distributed. It was literally
easier to just do an all reduce.
That's multiGPU, not multiGPU machines.
I don't know. Can you not just do that
over multiple machines? I think there's
some setup associated with it.
Made an N. Should I create an NPR?
depends what the end is.
If it is like the uh two pixel Flappy
Bird or whatever, no. If it's like a
full If it's something at least the
complexity of like a full game of Flappy
Bird, then sure.
Try to hack something together. Cool.
Xlink. Oh,
yeah. Let me do that.
All right. We'll do that real quick and
then we'll get focusing. All right.
I have to update the one on the website,
too, is the annoying thing.
publish this.
Okay, that one's done.
like squared. If it has any use, then
yeah,
I mean, go PR it and I'll look at it at
the least.
I don't bite you for pring stuff as long
as it's not AI slop.
Is it is it linked on um
on here as well?
I don't think I have it on Twitch.
Jay Suarez. Cool.
Saved on both of those.
So at least those two are updated.
Warberg has been running
nicely on puffer
plus 5 billion steps 1.2 mil
and obs are huge. Uh our new
vectorization should help a little bit.
It buffers the transfers. Pleasure to
work with. Good. I'm trying to make 40
way nicer. It's just so much work, man.
Dropout and norm that was missing. Why
do you need dropout?
Dropout's for regularization. You have
unlimited data.
Norm sometimes helps, sometimes does
not. Um, we don't have norm layers
because norm layers are incredibly
incredibly inefficient. They're very,
very slow. It's actually very difficult
to implement a good norm kernel. You
look at NARMS and it looks very simple.
Yeah, you get an absolutely horrible um
cross terms in the backward pass for an
RMS norm.
Yeah. So, we're absolutely not going to
have anything that looks like this in
the puffer codebase. What the heck even
is this?
own data center server that we don't
want to Overfit. I see.
Is this thing? Oh, this is a finance
one, right? Yeah, I remember that.
Lance. Okay.
And every time I hear Lance,
this is what I think of
here. This is you, right? You're this
dude.
Think of the Pokemon Emerald Gym Leader.
Awesome name.
Is that your Is that actually your first
name's Lance? Cuz if so, that's an
awesome freaking name.
Yeah. I get to be Joseph.
Biblical
Lancelot. Are you kidding me?
Oh, that's awesome.
That is freaking awesome.
I mean, with a name like that, you've
got you have like an obligation to be,
you know, like Jack's tech paladin,
right?
Hey, Jess.
the right hand man to the pharaoh.
That's fair.
Yo, Jess, we got uh we got no torch
training.
It's about 5,000 lines at the moment.
We're going to try to get it down to
4,000.
No torch required.
Static memory. Fully reproducible. Fully
deterministic training.
Still using their tensors. Nope.
Literally nothing. Jess, it doesn't even
compile with torch. Like we're not even
using torch in compilation. So it
compiles like 5x faster.
Oh, there's something else.
act to go.
That's weird. Whatever. Did we give it a
torch? Yes, we did. It's going to still
be torch compatible.
We're kind of going through some stuff
at the moment, looking for um
looking for fluff.
to get this into like just iteratively
we refactor this until it's less stupid.
Actually, I can just say like
We'll get like the first couple little
ops done first.
Yeah. So, this is one of the things I'm
not sure about is like we have a couple
weird kernels like this transpose01 and
stuff,
but this actually looks very very
similar to the code before, doesn't it?
Kind of just goes to show you torch
wasn't really doing anything.
I mean, I only really see the problems
in the body of
Well, maybe we'll actually be able to
see once it applies uh refactors.
When you replay the runs, how do you
chain multiple runs together? Is that a
built-in feature
when you replay? Uh, it just resets when
it finishes an an episode. Yeah, that's
just normal.
Here's a restroom real quick. Yeah, give
me a few minutes, folks. I'll be back
and then we will start refactoring for
real.
Okay.
When did you get rid of torch? Hey,
Jess.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh when did you replay when you replay
the runs? Okay. No, that's I answered
that. Cool.
Let's figure out where all this crap is
coming from, right?
I think we've just have this massive
create function.
Yeah, look at this init function. This
is huge.
How long do you plan on streaming today?
Long time.
Me stream long time.
Oh, I have to not modify the file while
it's doing that. Okay.
Let it do this first so I can actually
read the freaking code.
I don't think they are using a prop for
all that hot.
Do you mind explaining what you did
different from Torch in your
implementation?
Well, we weren't really using Torch for
that much to begin with, Jess. Like we
basically chipp thesis it to the point
that we had five custom kernels and the
autograd was just calling backward like
five times. So what's the point? The
design of torch also sucks. Like by
default you're allocating memory all
over the damn place. Um
I had I was not able to get torch to
actually be deterministic even though um
even though it's like uh couplass is
supposed to be.
It was pretty stupid honestly.
Let's just have it un uneline
everything.
You don't save line count by doing this
[ __ ]
We also have some nice other things just
like we have stuff in contiguous memory
so a lot of our ops are way simpler
but like the goal is not to just make
Torch but better like I wouldn't go try
to make Torch but better unless it
really sucked at what it did. Like Torch
has some problems, but most of the
problems are not the execution of the
design, it's the design itself. Like,
okay, sure, some of their code's a mess.
Actually, a lot of their code's a mess,
but
um
it's mostly like just too many tiny
little tiny little ops getting chained
together, not in the same kernel.
So,
let's not do too much of this.
And I'm pretty sure these just do not
get used. So
I think we can just delete all this
profile. J
So, essentially a lot of today, the
reason I didn't stream the last couple
days is because it was really, really
stupid Claude slop crap.
Now it's like much more directed. So at
least it's going to be me looking
through and actively trying to find
stuff that we can improve with the code
and looking for redundancy and stuff. Um
the last couple days the problem was
that we just had such a huge amount to
refactor and each individual op was
pretty stupid. But like there's
essentially nothing to even do with it.
And it was a very strongly verifiable
process as well.
Like stuff like this is just ah okay, we
no longer need the profiler here. We can
move the profiler in and boom. Look, the
Python gets a little simpler.
Yeah, we'll put we'll put this window
here
and this window here.
Nice.
Check our stats.
67. Good.
Very good.
This function is ridiculous, right? Like
you shouldn't have to do this.
In the meantime,
we had a whole mess of notifications.
So, apparently somebody had a cool end.
Hello. What's this?
What's this?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's survivors.
I'm trained with browserbased front-end
environments.
Yeah, this is not this doesn't work.
scammers.
Do not say, "Oh, we can just do the
thing that the puffer does." If you did
not know the perf requirements, my guy.
I mean, this is just so that we know um
memory usage, right?
Got to love seeing people building nice
ends.
Honestly, if I were going to pick like
one programmer to go read a bunch of his
code to try to learn more myself, it
would be Rison.
Okay. GPU memory after close leak is 121
megs
Yeah, we'll just do that and then we'll
do
I'd really like it if there would be a
way to not have this be a thing.
Oh, wait. We have to do set up. We need
to build this.
Wonder if it's worth making this not
even need the Python wrapper at all. The
only thing is our dashboard.
I guess our sweeps in for our dashboard
still going to need torch.
It's pretty nice to see these 7sec full
solve experiments on my low-end machine.
That's pretty cool.
Okay. So, plus zero.
Okay. It's plus zero. Cool.
What do you consider low-end? Uh, I have
a 5070 in this machine. This was a
pre-built for 2K.
So,
how much is an Apple laptop these days?
I know I'm going to get the stupid ads
now for this, but
you can't even buy a pro for that
anymore, can you? Oh, you can. You can
buy a
Where is it?
You can buy an M4 Pro for 2K. So, same
price as uh one of these slow ass
things.
There you go.
M1 is going around 700.
Isn't that like super old now though,
dude?
Okay, maybe this is not a low-end
machine. This is a mid-end machine
realistically. Yes, this is not a
low-end machine.
But come on, 2K 5070.
You can rent a 5070 for what? 10 cents
an hour on vast.
I don't know why their prices are so
screwy.
We're 5070 on here.
5070 Ti is 9 cents an hour. 5070 is 8
cents an hour.
I think we've made it like plenty
accessible.
You're able to get a 5080 machine for
cheaper
new. Good deal if you did.
I just get mine from Main Gear because I
have the fewest problems with them.
New solid deal then.
And I bought this thing in like five
minutes, man, because I realized I
needed a desktop in Florida and I needed
something to be here.
I figured, yay, it won't be so high-end
that I can like waste time gaming on it.
And then I realized, oh wait, the game I
spend the most time on is freaking
Runescape. I can play that on a potato.
Okay, this is why we write the test
instead of telling it to just do stuff
cuz that would have been a 16meg leak.
That would have been really really bad
because you would not have seen this
until like uh what 160.
Yeah, you wouldn't have seen this till
several hundred experiments into a
sweep.
Well, now the leak is gone. What the
heck?
Wait, excuse me.
How the hell does this make any sense?
One
How's the progress been up here? We have
uh we have super fast training, static
memory, fully reproducible,
deterministic, same result every time
with no torch. So, I'd say it's going
pretty well.
I just have a bunch of crap to clean up
though.
Minecraft clone would be
um
I don't know what a good I don't want to
do that project man because that would
be a substantial project and like if I
do anything if I do any like custom game
Ms at the moment that aren't aren't
client work or aren't like, you know,
investigating a new branch of science
would probably be porting Runescape
stuff.
Yeah, this shutdown function is still
massive.
any of that you can't haven't made just
like
it's a big thing from here and honestly
it's probably really shitty because
the easiest way to do it is very AI
heavy
um
I don't think it's like AI heavy doable
by somebody who literally doesn't
program but it is like AI doable by an
experienced programmer using
approximately two brain cells
um which is just like porting
there's colison but then they're also
like their existing private servers
uh for Runescape like I would think that
porting that engine and then specific
scenarios which is one of the things I
started doing on stream in fact even the
inferno would be like finishing that
project would be a good start
because the the only thing I can
basically think of that's left is having
a really really big environment. There
are some test environments that we still
need. For instance, like Tim Socabon
environment is going to be incredibly
helpful. Um, and there probably are a
few others that I'm not going to know
until I see them. There are also some
open NPRs that could use review that I
need to go review and I haven't had time
to do yet that will be useful. But I
think for big environments, it's like
assume we're going to solve neural MMO 3
sometime reasonably soon. uh this year
at the least and then like neural MMO 4
will have to happen.
I also don't know like if I just go port
the entire thing if I'm going to run
into tr like legal trouble with that. I
don't think so.
How are the foundation models?
Uh, you could Jess. I think it would be
it would be quite difficult.
It's not the reason I'm excited about RL
though.
I don't you don't need foundation models
for RL to be useful when you can just
train them super fast.
Is it still worth learning C and C++?
What do you mean? Is it still worth
learning C and C++? Like abso
freakingutely for C. C++ is a complete
disaster. I hate it. You'll see that I'm
very quickly deleting most of the C++y
things in here and getting them to look
more C style. C is like the only thing
that's worth learning. Honestly,
it's so good.
Simple M's. Oh, hey, there's Tim
himself. I'm still waiting on that so
end. That one is going to be super
awesome. Simple M's vers more complex
curriculum learning. Trade-off between M
simplicity and achieving best possible
policy.
Uh, not necessarily, Tim. You can have
very, very complex M's that have a
smooth enough learning curriculum, like
naturally, for you to just be able to do
very, very well at them without having
to do anything fancy with curriculum.
It just depends on the problem.
All right. What do we add here? 1037
lines.
At least we don't have discussed and
close implementation anymore.
Okay, we got weird shapes shenanigans to
handle.
A lot of weird shape shenanigans to
I'm just looking for bloat is what I'm
doing.
Okay, this is a dumb way of handling it,
but it's fine.
Yeah, a lot of the shape stuff is pretty
bloated, I think.
Shape stuff. And then what else?
Okay, let me read this create function
for now and then we'll figure out the
shapes. What about Rust? [ __ ] that
language.
Look, the only there's one redeeming
thing about C++, which is you can just
ignore it and write C in it. Rust is
just bad.
It's like smart smart nerds focusing on
completely the wrong thing for god knows
what reason.
At least I can work on deleting all the
C++y garbage from this.
Okay, we got default stream. What the
hell is this
Action space stuff. We just have like a
lot of little things, don't we?
this MK1D thing.
It's all the same problem though, right?
It's just like being jank making a
tensor.
Probably some stuff we can look at here,
but pretty small.
H
is quite a bit. I think the main thing
is going to be in how we're making these
tensors.
This is like somebody who's very smart
with a very different style from my own.
where I don't think that that style is
inherently completely stupid.
So wait, it just gets data
device and DT type.
So you have a shape.
Yeah. Shape. Oh. Yeah. This is gross.
That's a problem.
Oh, they don't have it's not open
source.
Good job, man.
Yeah, we're going to need more than four
dims.
I don't know what it's doing with this
plan mode. Crap. Um,
Why is it void star data?
I want charge star bites.
That's hugging face. Cool.
Matrix B.
Try that little P chief puffing officer.
It's going well.
We are doing the highest performance RL
now without torch. So that's pretty
cool.
No torch needed.
the thing is I really want this to be C
style. So I don't want to give this any
functions.
But we'll uh we'll start with this for
now.
Can people still find jobs
but doing regular RL? My guy, you
realize that I could literally work in
any area of ML that I wanted to within
two months worth of background research,
right?
It's like math engine science. If you're
good at any one, uh if you're good at
any one of these,
you're going to do fine. If you're good
at two, uh you can like do stuff like
this. If you're good at three, well,
there really aren't that many people
that are good at all three.
So I think that the goal here is just
going to be
So, I think that this will get us into
clean shape casts. Maybe
that'll save us a lot. And then from
there, we can probably go into um
Colonels
cuz Colrons is going to be most of the
bloat.
while this is doing this in the
meantime.
So, like realistically, we've got a
little bit of junk in here, but it's
only 500 some odd lines for
vectorization.
Uh, we've got the binding file, which is
a binding file,
and then most of the stuff is the models
and kernels, right? So, this is 15.
Yeah, that's like 3K plus. It's almost
threequarters of their code.
Maybe like 70% of the code
is just in models and kernels.
So that's going to be the main main
thing to clean up.
I just need it to be like not crap today
so we can actually start on it.
6k
- one is 5k. Okay.
what you working on?
Uh, well,
we have all of our training code in nice
uh raw CUDA now. So, I'm currently
cleaning up our new CUDA RL trainer.
use cloud code. Now,
I keep saying I want to get rid of it,
and I really do.
It's kind of weird, honestly, man,
because
so the nicer the code base is, the less
I use it.
But the like the problem is that
the last whole bunch of work has
basically just been figuring out how to
deal with the massive mess that Torch
has.
And it's just been like applying
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
refactor ops until we get Torch into
something that is not gross that still
trains.
And uh LM is very good at that cuz it's
very very strongly verifiable in very
small chunks of work that are really
obnoxious to do manually.
But like ask it to design anything, ask
it to make any sort of reasonable
decision at all, it'll do it wrong every
time.
So, I'm kind of accepting that it has a
use
while I will still claim that people
overuse the crap out of it and do really
really dumb stuff with it.
See, this all of this is just um a
refactor update.
keyboard.
Uh, Widow Tournament Edition V4 75% with
ORM switches.
I like this keyboard.
So, I think it's going to be a little
bit more of figuring out the shape.
What we have? We got puff tensor.
Okay. I really I don't like that we have
these methods hanging off of it,
but bite shape and dim size.
Uh, it didn't bother to do a enum, did
it?
That's okay for now.
I want to at least get the create
uh the creations of this to be
reasonable.
Wait, bite endm zero.
Does this thing have a stupid
constructor on it?
No.
I suppose we can also I mean this is
like really simple [ __ ] So I in order
to be more interesting on this stream I
think we can just go look at the
kernels. As long as this hasn't broken
it, we'll just go look at the kernels.
Cuz this is like this is really easy
[ __ ] I can do this off stream in the
evenings.
This is what I mean by they're just like
a million of these really dumb refactor
ops. It's like let's try to do it like
this. Let's try to do it like this.
Let's try to do it like this. How much
code did that save? Okay, what's it look
like now?
Right.
So, I was hoping that today I could
stream some actually more interesting
stuff looking at the um the kernels and
seeing what like what we have in there
and what can be improved. In fact, let's
just like start looking at this now
Okay. So, the top layer that we have
here, we've got model C++. This has
everything on the C++ side, right? So
all these four decks here, these are for
kernels. You see that these have cuda
types in them. So those are all just for
kernels. So really this starts right
here where we have our allocator in
here. This allocator should not be in
models. We'll figure out where to put
these. Um
allocator is really really simple.
It could even be even simpler honestly.
Yeah, this should be like half this
amount of code. So, all the allocator
has to do is give us contiguous memory
buffers for parameters, gradients, and
whatever else we want. You went to MIT?
Yes, I finished my PhD two years ago, a
little less.
And now I do open source reinforcement
learning and I try to make the field
that I spent the last decade of my life
on uh actually be fast and sane. and
we've had quite some success with that.
All of our RL stuff is close to 10,000
times faster um now compared to when I
graduated.
Like actually 10,000x faster. Not making
[ __ ] up. That's pretty cool.
Uh pry buffers.
Yeah, cool. All the buffers are in here
or whatever.
more freaking highle. Okay, so there's
just like a ton a ton of
um duped like headers and jank in here,
right?
And then we by 380 this is where we get
to actual code
I mean but it doesn't really do anything
right? We have native encoder.
Okay. Well, like look, this is this is
just it being stupid, right? This is
like
this is the fact that this is now not
done in terms of layers, right? It's the
entire multi-layer mining group in one
ST. So, duh, that's going to suck.
Okay.
Then we got the policy.
Here's Muan. Muan I think is actually
pretty concise
except for the tensor creations, right?
Yeah, except for the tensor creations.
Okay. Well, now at least now we know
where the bloat is in here. This is very
very bloated and it's mostly the boiler
plate and mostly the um creation of
tensors.
Uh what do we got? We got puffer lib C++
and we have models
cu.
So this is anything that has a launch
function.
Namings of stuff kind of suck in here.
So we got like five of these map mole
functions that are just couplass
rappers.
And then we have some
This is like just direct ported I
suppose from
uh from torch the orthogonal in it.
Let's see if this actually works.
859. Perfect. 978.
Cool.
Bunch of path and norms and clips. Just
random little functions.
A lot of random little functions.
Yeah. The sad thing about this is this
is this is death by a thousand cuts is
what it is. Is there a way to write
kernels that work on all types of GPUs?
Each company has its own supply chain.
Uh so it's more than just that, man.
It's
you're like if you write CUDA kernels,
they'll work on whatever Nvidia GPU, but
optimization can be very different for
Blackwell chips.
And it's also very dependent on what
types of kernels you're writing. So like
the kernels that LLMs use for giant
models are very different than the
kernels that we use for very small
models.
So, like, yes, technically there are a
bunch of things out there that make
kernels that work anywhere. It's just
that at the moment they're all very
slow. And they mostly do it by putting a
bunch of uh abstracted crap in between
you and the hardware, which of course
makes it very hard to think about how
your thing is going to be performant on
different targets.
We're not too concerned about that at
the moment. We're concerned about fast
and simple.
Um, and fast and simple equals just
write your CUDA.
So that's what we're doing.
Yeah. So right here, this is like a
couple hundred lines of death by a
thousand cuts.
We also have all these like rapper. I
don't think we need these everywhere, do
we? Hang on one second.
Okay,
so we don't even need all of this stuff.
Does Puffer not rely on PyTorch at all?
As of today, for training, no.
We still have it in sweeps. We still
have an optional torch back end. It'll
still be compatible, but um I'm pretty
sure we're going to end up with about
the same amount of code before without
the torch dependency and faster with
better with some additional nice
features just by dropping torch.
It's pretty good.
Okay. So the trick here is that um
yeah I think we should not have a
separate
models C++ and models CU
right
cuz look otherwise you end up hiding
stuff.
What happened here?
I did slash compact
and it didn't compact
the non lml stuff. Yeah, it's pretty
cool.
They do nonm nonm stuff. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean, watch this. Like, this is my local
machine, right? Which is not even a
super high-end machine.
I think the thing is that models should
just be written in CUDA
because otherwise look at the look at
the API surface, right?
You see all this stuff? Like a bunch of
these functions get called literally
once and you have a wrapper.
You have a wrapper for calling this.
Like this function should not exist.
It's huge adoption. I mean, it really
is, Tim.
I keep seeing people doing stuff with
that with it, even though I haven't
really been promoting it all that much
lately. I've kind of just been grinding
on the new release.
Yeah, this will end up saving a bunch of
code. Like there are a whole bunch of
these kernels that literally get called
once that have a wrapper for no reason
other than like the C++ to CUDA
boundary. I think you should just be
writing your code in CUDA C and that's
it.
like you should not need launch function
wrappers, right? Unless there's actually
a lot of logic that's needed to
determine a launch, you should just be
able to call launches in line in your
code. That's way better.
It's way way better.
This should end up deleting like a 100
lines worth of wrappers, I would
imagine, and then additional like maybe
100 lines worth of headers.
I guess then the question is do we want
launch functions in our kernels file as
well or do we want the kernels file to
be purely device side
cuz like there are operations that you
need that are reusable that require you
to launch multiple kernels, right?
I mean, but realistically, right,
if I look in here,
this stuff is fine. Right.
These are just kernels.
There's some constants and things that
need to be moved around, but like this
is chill. This is chill. Most of our
kernel code is pretty decent.
I mean, there's some stuff that can be
simplified and compacted,
but we don't really have any
there's not like abstracted jank in here
anymore. I worked very hard to make sure
there wouldn't be.
I guess I kind of signed myself up for
an extra bunch of hours of work by doing
this. But I mean, realistically, I think
that this saves me like this saves me
time in the long run. And uh this should
not delay our release. This basically
just means I have to work a bunch of
extra nights in the next week or two.
But then I think this pretty much just
gets us back on schedule and uh and
cleaner and with like nice new features
and stuff.
It'll be good.
It's probably just a lot of them got to
get merged, right?
Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised if the
reason that we have these is because uh
you know, porting the torch ops
directly, Torch does stuff this way. I
think we're just going to end up with a
larger num a a larger number of small
wait is it no a smaller number of larger
kernels
cuz this like back and forth from host
to GPU [ __ ] has to stop.
It's really dumb.
Like what the hell is this? Come on.
So, I I'm still optimistic we can get
this thing down to about 4k lines.
There's a lot of waste in here.
Let me see what I would think that it
should look like at the end of the day.
It probably left a bunch of logic in
here. There's no way it's this long,
right?
Oh no, it left the fords
declared only.
Okay, so this is a mess but not that
bad.
I like to look at the line counts
because I have an idea of how much code
things should take. So I kind of do this
to see what I think where we think we
should end up. Like I think that this
models.h H should end up at like 3400.
Um
this will end up at 900.
I think this could end up at like 700
600 and this is like400. Yeah. So we can
cut about 1,000 lines.
I think we can cut about 1,000 lines.
And this 6,000 number is really like
5,000 because puffernet is something
different.
So is 4k lines good if we have like 500
devoted to vec.
Um 1kish for the main trainer
and 25 uh was it like 500 for models and
20 wait 500 for models and 2k for
kernels.
That would be pretty good to me. I'd be
happy with that. And then how many of
these files do we even want?
I think if we can get rid of one or two
of these files as well. Little bit of
merging.
I guess I really just don't like theh
files here.
Problem is we can't do anything about
theh files with vecans
because this is needed for static
compilation right
but this should reduce some of it
and then
I think merging of kernels is going to
be a major one.
I really want kernels.cu to just be like
this clean thing that has actually
useful
functions
that you can use for um like most of
what we'd want to be doing in our RL
work.
Actually, you know, sections of this
code are already pretty good and
sections of it are still pretty bad. I'd
say
uh like most I'd say at least half the
Colonel's code's really good. Is really
pretty good. Half of it still crap
actually. Let's see in the meantime what
I don't understand why the models the
models file is like this.
Not this. Oh no. proper liab models.h
why is theh file like this?
So like,
And you register,
you essentially just register the shapes
and you give it a pointer. Was it? You
give it a pointer and a shape.
Okay, those are just high level uh
PPO loss.
This doesn't get called at all. Okay.
So, it's got stale crap in here, right?
Oh, no. This is cold in here,
huh?
This is cold in here.
Interesting.
The signatures on these just kind of
suck.
Okay. Like at the very least, right,
there's there is some stuff here where
it's like it's done this.
It's done all the layers together.
Yeah. Like why isn't this in the encoder
right
like right here? Why is this not in the
encoder?
Oh, okay. I see the design is actually
not that that bad in that case.
It's not that bad.
We will have to decide if we keep
classes around at all.
Okay, so that's minus 81 lines.
And we just made the models file.
Actually got a little bit shorter.
And
uh the cuda here, this got shorter.
So this was just a pure win.
Let me see if there's any more file
level stuff I want to mess with before
cuz then I can make a commit at least.
I guess the only other question is like
is there a reason to create a CUDA C++
division in the first Nice.
I really don't like the idea of having
to introduce boundaries, right? Like,
oh, this is a a CUDA to C++ boundary.
You need headers across this, right?
I actually don't even like the static
compilation boundary that we have
for vecend.
I also like the idea of just having no
C++ files in Puffer Web.
that removes 1.h.
And I suppose you still need this back
end,
but like
this.H is way longer than it should be,
right? Cuz it has this stuff in theH.
So assuming that we can Oh, yeah. And
like
there's also some crap in here we no
longer use.
I swear every time I end up splitting
stuff up into a bunch of files, I end up
merging it back.
It's really really next to impossible to
maintain um a good project design when
you have a ton of files all over the
place
cuz it just it distorts like it distorts
the amount of redundancy that you have
in your project.
No C++ files.
No C files.
Nice.
Right.
Now we have a total of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight files.
Puffer lib. We got models, kernels,
Cool. So then what's going to happen is
models.h will get merged back into
models.cu
This should actually be minus a good
chunk of code.
I don't know. Header header files are
like
anything that causes you to duplicate
code is a very antihuman design
because then you have to go manually
update it in multiple places.
So,
I really don't like I don't like um
I don't like header files
unless you're just writing your entire
code in a header file like header only.
That's cool.
This actually will give us a meaningful
um a meaningful chunk of the goal. It
should at least.
And this gives us a very clean surface
to think about as well.
Each nfest the whole code is in ah
though dude. The h is the source code
for our ends. If you look at them, the h
files are not just declaring the types.
When I say I don't like header files, it
doesn't mean I don't like files that end
withh. Right? It means I don't like
files that consist of all of the um the
decks for your functions.
That I don't like.
I have a here's a great question.
Why can't you just
eliminate
mouse? Here's a dumb question.
That's like the type of stuff I would
like actually want to learn more about.
I'll go look at what Zig does if it
makes sense.
Regular Luciov.h just declaring. Yes, it
is.
I don't know. It's honestly like
it's one of those things that I think
very few pro programmers actually
understand the internals behind this and
then like a lot of dummies just get
stockholded into thinking that oh yeah,
you need to have the API defined in a
file like this or whatever which is just
not true anywhere else.
Also, I didn't turn this auto accept
edit thing on. It just turns itself on
and it keeps giving itself more perms
without me doing anything as well.
I think Enthropic just hates thinking.
Would you be open to providing brief
private feedback on an environment I've
been working on? PhD student. Yep. If
so, how to contact you
uh send you NH? Yeah, that works. You
can just send it to me on Discord. You
can link it or you can link me to GitHub
on uh on wherever.
If you send me stock market.h, I'm going
to get suspicious.
But if it's academic, then sure.
Uh, PhD students get free advice.
Finance companies have to pay.
No. How did this end up with more code?
Oh, it didn't remove this yet. Okay.
Yeah, Claude will just like randomly
delete all of the comments from code
for no
But once this file is gone, then this
gets uh
thought it was going to be minus 200.
Possibly it just didn't delete the uh
the headers though. We'll go see.
No, it did.
Okay. So, it's only minus about 100
lines. Then minus 100 is still minus
100.
Yep. Delete the models file. And now
my 100
Okay. What much more manageable, right?
We've got thousandline puffer lip cu.
We've got a 1400 line models file line
kernels file. We got some bindings and
vecan. And then this you can ignore.
And then this matches perf as well.
Yeah, it adds useless comments and then
deletes like the actual like, hey, this
is how the numeric work here so that it
doesn't explode.
I would like to have this be one file,
the 1.H file.
ve of age binding age.
Wait, how does this work?
Oh.
Uh, I think we can do this.
Let's see if that does if that works.
I would just It deletes a little bit of
code.
It um
removes a lot of silly things.
It' be very nice if we can just do this,
you know.
and then if we can do this let's assume
that this just removes I don't know 50
lines right
900 to go
that kind of has some dated stuff
I mean but the big one in my mind is
probably models and kernels is where the
bulk of the the fluff is
right now.
I'm actually I'm going to let this just
go and um yeah, we'll do that.
I'll be right back. I'm going to make
myself a mug of tea and then we'll
proceed.
And uh okay, it hasn't removed the back
end.
So 5912
is going to go down to
I swear if it got longer.
How did it get longer?
How on earth did it get longer, man?
I don't know how it broke that. There
must be um
ah
why that didn't get
before.
Okay. So, what's in here that it got
longer?
probably just has stuff in a stupid
order.
They're needed for proper lic which only
the top section.
Okay. Well, that's weird, but fine for
now.
Well, okay. We end up with I think now
small amount to be done in beckend
small amount to be done in puffer lib I
think those files are like
this this they're like 80% done so
basically all the main complexity is the
3k lines here which is Good.
Okay, so it's now all going to be in
models and kernels.
Yeah. Look. Norm reduce clip by norm.
This is stupid. You see
this is completely stupid.
C and C++.
Good.
What on earth?
It's funny.
Hello. What is the goal? To have the
fastest, simplest, and overall best
reinforcement learning out there.
here. Watch this train in like I don't
know six seconds on my local desktop.
There we go.
This work?
Didn't break it right.
I'm trying to see if this model's just
dumb. If I just delete this line, what
happens?
Literally nothing happens. It's just
done. Cool.
Why
is this here?
What if I put this up here? Does
everything explode?
Okay. So, it's just like it's really bad
at organizing stuff like so
scale.
All right. So, we have like we have a
ton of really stupid drapper functions
down here.
I think this is the main thing that we
need to understand is the layout of this
file because really the only places
where we have jank that I've kind of let
the language model do really dumb stuff
is some of the really small kernels down
here. Uh the ones higher up are
handwritten. They're very good. It's all
these little stupid kernels right here.
Pretty much down from here, right? 1490.
So, we've got Yeah, this is See, this is
all reasonable stuff up here.
Um, so it's it's literally just
it's 200 lines of kernel code in here.
And then I don't even know how much of
this. A lot of this
Okay. So, small puff tenser.
This stuff relatively okay.
Relatively okay at least.
Native encoder, native decoder,
mining
policy.
Wait, why is this
but that's why we didn't save anything
on these declarations.
Okay, this is when it starts to get
super giant. So,
we have a whole lot of Matt Mole
rappers.
Is this actually the best way to do an
orthogonal in it?
This seems super jank.
Oh [ __ ] this Malik.
Interesting.
There lots. It really is just like
it's death by a thousand cuts, but I
feel like I still have to find at least
a few more big things.
Like what is this?
remove CNN's.
Good luck, man.
Okay. So there is actually stuff we can
do.
I think a lot of these are only used
once.
Thanks. I'm trying to figure out and
visualize all code sections.
Wait. Well, this is this thing here is a
mess. Um, this is like brand new and it
needs major refactoring. When I'm done
with it, it'll be very nice because
it'll be about the length of the old
code, but not dependent on torch at all.
and
uh CNN's are supposed to give you
spatial locality,
which is arguably useful in chess. Kind
of questionable.
Okay, we'll do that for now. That ought
to be a good bit of clean up.
I mean, it just basically there are a
ton of little kernels. Um because So,
why is the code like this, right? Well,
it's because I ported this incrementally
from torch and torch is like this,
right? So, essentially
every single part of torch is wrong. So,
the code that we are going to end up
with is going to be a similar length,
but it's going to look very different
from the torch code,
which is why we have all this refactor
crap.
And I hope that this doesn't kill. Are
these guys actually smart? Let's see.
No, no, it's not.
Okay.
Well, that's okay.
Do you have any suggestions just latest
square per square features?
8.
Okay.
I don't necessarily have any great
ideas, Jess, on this. I mean, you can go
look up the encoding that the other the
other guys used. Is it big?
We just want like some reasonable small
encoding and then hopefully stack the
recurrent cell deeper is going to be my
guess.
add stride to represent. Yes, you can.
But chess is not large scale, man. Chess
is very small.
The problem is that like we want it to
go really fast and CNN's are not really
fast. They're only just like kind of
fast.
reduces dimension. How does that work
with 8 by8?
Uh it also reduces channel script
destroy confirm that hurt learning.
Yeah,
I believe it.
classic. Just um break my code and bill
me.
Such a stupid workflow. This is so so
stupid.
I mean, sadly, like this is actually the
best way to do this at the moment, as
dumb as that is
because
this is sadly the best way to do this
because it's just a dumb really a bunch
of really dumb refactor ops and like
until it gets into the state where it's
pretty close to the final, it's just
really really gross and bloated to edit
this by hand. Like I basically
I want to be doing the fine edits by
hand if that makes sense.
How does it manage to break train? No
idea. But it did
That would be minus 50 lines though.
Figure out what the hell it did.
It's actually,
yeah, that's actually better than minus
50 lines because it's minus
100 from models.cu and adding some to
kernels.
We want the kernels file to be big and
basically everything else to be small.
Like the idea is that essentially
everything gets just chunked into a
bunch of nicely fused kernels.
Actually, I don't even know how you
could break it doing this.
I'm going to assume that this will be
fixed and then I'm going to look start
looking for next stuff.
Okay, so this is another big one here,
right? Like we could potentially.
I think the Muan update loop itself
could just get combined.
Am I ignorant? Wait. Transformer based.
No, I'm just alterbased.
Um well it's just the thing for CNN's is
its locality. CNN's are the fast thing
that model that just
like if you were doing images and asking
how to replace columns I'd just say well
you shouldn't that's the right thing to
use. Um,
the thing is that you're in the middle,
right, where there's some spatial
locality to chess, but it's not the same
as with pixels.
So, you're kind of using the bias, but
kind of not. So, it's weird. It's a
weird in between.
No, this still not work.
Did they just like
I'm going end up having to revert all
this crap, right?
We're not doing this.
We're just reverting.
Models are [ __ ] dumb.
My fault for trying to make him do too
much at once though.
But then this got us down to 1300 in
models.
kind of have a weird in between here,
don't we?
Can we do theoretical research like
finding an alternative to CNN
outside of academia or bigly? Well, yes.
It's not theoretical either.
It's pretty practical.
You realize academia is just like a
bunch of grad students with no resources
whatsoever
like sitting around and hacking on
stuff, right?
So, I don't know how we're going to do
our uh our network architectures yet,
how this should look. But this is not
most of the code, is it?
So, now we're only halfway through the
code. Not even. We're third of the way
through the code. And then there's a
bunch of crap.
So, we got a bunch of maples here.
And then we got orthogonal in it.
And then
well, okay, some of these are getting
removed right by this update. About 100
lines of this is getting removed. But we
got a bunch of this crap.
And then we have the really chunky
kernels here.
really chunky kernels. I mean, we're
kind of just dying to signatures, right?
We're just dying to like signature call
bloat if it's 10 lines to call a
function.
And there you go.
it's mostly just rappers and crap,
right?
So I guess then the question the other
question we're going to have is like are
we comfortable having um
our strct types in our CUDA functions
because that would simplify if we
basically if we just treat CUDA as
h
I'm starting to understand.
I'm starting to understand how we do
this.
Like you all see the problem, right?
Like look at this. So you have a
function like this train, select and
copy that takes 10 tensors. All right,
it does a little bit of calc and then it
calls a kernel with like the 10 tensors
and the arcs in native types instead of
in these types,
right?
Like this could just be deleted and then
you could just call this at the site and
then this could even potentially just
take like you know the this could end up
just taking one strruct or something.
It's just a matter of whether we want to
have like custom strcts in the calls to
CUDA
which I mean realistically the answer is
yes right
like the low-level functions that are
just numerical ops or whatever they
should just use float or B float or
whatever.
Um,
Hey Liberty, we are doing uh
reinforcement learning without torch.
I have puffer lib working fully with no
torch
and
we are refactoring a whole bunch of
crap.
All right.
So, this is going to result in like
minus 100 lines. And then essentially
there's some lines to be saved in
emerging kernels that are very
important. But then the biggest thing is
going to just be from passing
We're going to have to pass. It's the
signatures are what's killing us
actually. You know,
it's actually kind of funny that like
okay, there is some bloated logic,
right? But I think it's mostly the
signatures that are killing us.
As long as it's deterministic,
it's fine if it changes the determinism
a bit.
869. Uh 5,010 lines because you ignore
puffer net. So this will take us under
5k.
I would really like this codebase to
look like, you know, 2K of kernels,
1k of puffer,
500 here, 500 here, or no, 500 here, and
then bindings.
I don't think there is. I just have to
check.
I think that's a 20 line save per one of
these that we do, isn't it?
I mean, with I think this saves us like
possibly a couple hundred lines across
this file.
If we did all of them.
It's chunky
pointers and dims not full P
temperatures.
A lightweight ARC is probably cleaner.
CUD CUDA kernel param limit is 4 KB.
So, it fits, but it's chunky.
CUDA devs in the chat? Does anybody know
if this is completely stupid to pass
full tensers to um
Compiler will optimize away any fields
the printer doesn't read. Interesting.
This will be so much cleaner though.
+ 15 - 13
It's actually a little shorter even
here.
Oh no, wait. Little longer. So, plus two
lines
Uh this cuda malik is not
Yeah, this should not be there.
I mean, you see what I mean though, like
about the amount of bloat. So, even
after I've optimized the crap out of
this, like look at this function sig,
right? This is awful.
I mean, it's just like so much bloat,
right?
submit this to one of those code review
YouTube channels.
Jess, you like the vast majority of
those are way worse programmers than I
am.
Like obviously this is crap, but you
don't have context for like why this is
crap. Why this is a much harder thing to
make not crap than normal and what I'm
doing to make it not crap. Right.
Like basically if you look at something
like this,
where is it?
All right. So if you look at something
like this
and you think this is bad code because
of all the nested for loops like you
basically don't have the ability to
think. You're just kind of applying the
blindly, oh nested for loops bad and not
actually looking at why they're here.
This is way more manageable.
Way more manageable.
this is cleaning up the puffer li um the
main puffer lib file as well. So, a
whole bunch of just like creation
garbage.
I mean, just you see way worse code base
than this unironically just for no
[ __ ] reason. Like, all the time is
the thing. Like, at least there's a
reason why this is difficult to get into
a good shape, right? Like this is trying
to go from a very very bad design that
is dependent on a ton of abstraction and
like just basically every possible thing
being done the wrong way into the simple
clean way and it just takes a lot of
work to get there cuz you don't want to
break training at any point, right? So
you basically instead of just
implementing the thing the clean way,
you have to do it by applying
transformations to the gross thing.
But we'll see after this uh how much
code we have left.
average number of SPS Liberty. I don't
even know. Super freaking fast. Like you
can hit close to 15 mil if I close the
stream and all the other stuff I have
running on my low-end machine.
So
it's fast. It's like 12 with stuff
closed. I think this is a slightly
smaller Yeah, this is a smaller net. But
don't worry, it's fast. It's faster than
torch by far.
Like this will gain us perf cuz we're
going to pure static mem and everything.
Okay, this is actually a very very nice
improvement. We now have 57.85 85
which subtract this
about uh 4,900
and if we look at this we now have
930 lines in puffer lilib cu which is
better
uh slightly more lines in modelscu which
I don't like to see but at least I think
that's like the first step in pushing
them into the kernel file and we have
fewer overall lines which is also good.
Placing torches. Hello Finn talk on
Saturday. Wilson Google meet. Thank you.
Yes, I did make slides. Uh I have to go
through them and actually figure out how
I'm going to put everything together. I
basically did a mashup of uh some neural
MMO stuff that's more accessible for my
thesis defense cuz I didn't get Did you
tell me what the audience was like? I
went for like a cool but accessible with
some amount of technical depth
and I so it's a mashup of some stuff
from neural MMO and then my RLC talk
with a couple uh things at the end about
what I've been working on recently.
It looks like you're doing cool stuff
with the drone as well.
Let's go through here and see what
Let's see what we have left.
undergrad. Cool. So, I will talk about a
bunch of cool stuff I've done and get
people excited, add some amount of
technical depth for those who want it.
It'll be cool.
I got to go through it a couple of times
at least.
not going to be polished to the extent
that my thesis defense was. Obviously,
that was three weeks of work to to
prepare that delivery.
But I will endeavor to give an
entertaining talk. It is also uh get
some people interested.
Yeah, this thing is freaking massive,
man. Look at this massive
Hey Zam, I'm going to see you around.
I've just been fighting and fighting and
fighting this nuts stuff. I mean, we
have torch out. We have super fast
compile. Now we're below 5k lines.
Ignore pufferet. That's not part of it.
Below 5k lines. One, two, three, four,
five. those five files.
The main thing that needs to happen is
this chunker needs to get smaller and
then kernels needs to be bigger but
clean.
A talk be recorded. Ask Finn and Sam. If
they invited me to give a talk, I will
give a talk. Finn and Sam have done all
sorts of cool stuff. Go check out their
drone stuff. You can follow them both on
X as well. They have done really awesome
stuff with puffer plus drone.
The Mulan code is so bad.
I think that gets fused as well.
Fuse everything.
Can anybody tell me if this is stupid?
Like basically I'm wondering why why do
we go back to host every time there's a
reduction off when it's literally the
same. It's the same launch arcs, right?
So like all this would just become one
thing.
You're never going to need to compute
the loss without immediately doing
backward anyways, right?
I guess technically gradient
accumulation maybe
does that matter?
really doesn't matter, right? Because
you would just do.
Yeah, because you just get the grats
anyways.
My best record talks. You're welcome to
report yourself if you'd like. Joseph,
should I stream the talk
and just turn the chat off?
I could do that.
just literally will do my uh normal
stream and then we'll go join talk gibs
talk. It'll be cool.
If that works, that'll save us another I
don't know 30-ish lines.
And then what else we have? I think Muan
I think actually I should do all of this
stuff in place for now.
Um,
we're going to end up changing this
anyways later, but we'll I think we
should just change all the functions to
be in place cuz I can't actually tell
how much code is for what now with the
way that I have this set up.
Is there ever a time when update epoch
is going to be more than one? Yes, Jess.
And actually update epochs is getting re
uh replaced with replay ratio
in puffer 4 which just means that like
on average this is the number of times
you use each sample and it can be float
value. It doesn't have to be an integer
and it's just included in puffer sweeps.
Now
it's pretty cool.
right, let's look for other stuff in the
meantime. So,
yeah, this thing sucks the way that we
have these tensors.
I'm going to try to mess with this
actually.
naming conventions. Jess, you'll get a
summary when I'm done changing stuff. If
I tell you all the new names and I
decide to keep changing them until
release, you're going to be annoyed.
They're in there.
The losses are there.
cudigraphs is like pruning or doing
something weird.
This would be very good if it worked
though because if we could get this to I
think a version of this works and is
going to be yeah minus 80 lines. Is that
more than minus 80? That is more than
minus 80 because that is minus
and 40 lines. That would be very good.
That would be very very good.
cuz you don't duke the massive six,
right?
Yeah,
that would be great.
That' actually be great. Of
Be right back. I use the restroom. I'm
going to get myself another mug of tea
and we shall continue for a bit.
Okay, this works. What do you want to
bet that it just reverted it?
Okay, cool.
Actually did it correctly.
Yeah, that means we should be catching
our errors most likely.
Solid, right?
Very good.
Make sure.
But that looks very very nice to me.
And did we keep our
Yeah. 12 line price.
So we now are 4,800 lines.
4800.
That's good.
This is just going to be so we can
actually see how much code each thing is
taking up.
Um, I actually don't really want these
tied to a strruct, but for now I need to
see how much code they're taking up.
We'll save us a few lines of forex as
well.
Oh, well that's really bad. That's like
really bad for us.
Yeah. So, it misinterpreted. That's
fine.
That's at least some of it.
cuz we basically can't see how much code
the mro is taking up.
three.
And this should save just a little bit
of code. But then the main thing is
we're going to see the groupings
and then we'll be able to essentially do
a good assessment of um what we can
actually save in
models
which should only need to be another
actually quite a bit. I would like that
file to be short. There really should
not be that much in there.
So that should be fine.
I am a little lost with how to start
with RL. Should I use gym or start with
puffer lib? Coding RL. I want to get
into coding RL agents.
Uh, well, Jim will be super freaking
slow, so I don't recommend that. Jim
also doesn't give you a training
implementation. It actually gives you
basically nothing other than an API and
a ridiculously slow multipprocessing
back end. So, if you want a uh a good
way to get started, check this out.
This is going to be all of my best
advice and uh pretty concrete like do
this and this and this all in one place.
It'll get you starting writing some
stuff very quickly and it'll fill in
theoretical gaps along the way.
Anybody else? Shouldn't be.
Uh,
mic settings look fine. Is my audio
screwed up for anybody else?
Never mind. It's good. That art applies
everything.
It definitely doesn't get to be 335
line. So, put the code back
and then I can actually look at it and
see. Um,
I suppose I can start in the meantime,
but it's kind of tough, but without it
being
without it being set up nicely.
I suppose it's going to be like coarse
um medium fine. So coarse is just like
having this thing do big chunks of
stuff. Medium is going to be like me
tagging little things here and there.
And then fine is going to be me editing
the rest of it by hand.
There's some stuff that it's like I just
can't believe that it takes this much
code to do an orthogonal when it's
literally just calling a solver, right?
Muon step is painful to look at, but
like we're not going to really save code
here. We might save some Perf.
I mean, the only other thing I can see
here is possibly the um
the tensor creation patterns.
We also don't know if orthogonal
initialization actually does anything
to be fair.
I don't want to mess with that though
until we have blade.
Okay, so
we clean up.
We went from
uh that is sketchy.
I don't see how we would have saved 200
lines. It must have deleted something,
right?
Apparently not. Apparently, there was
just a bunch of redundant frame.
So, that's cool because that means we
are now at 5600.
5600 lines.
That is very good.
Oh, and I also got to check on
check on Spencer.
We're good for now.
Okay.
I'm going to try one of these
uh these puff tensor allocations.
Like if I do this
equals,
Let's just see
what happens if I just do this.
That's way better, isn't it?
I like that much more.
It's not really going to save us any um
code, unfortunately.
in the same scope as declaration?
It does work
inside function. So that's a little
sketch, right?
I think this is how you have to do it.
the inside function parameter doesn't
work.
They're automatically zero initialized.
That's nice.
That will actually save us a few lines
throughout the program. It also just
makes stuff way nicer.
And all it needs is the shape.
C99.
Very clean.
And then literally because of that the
uh you can do view just by editing the
shape
which is really nice.
We can actually make a puff view
function so easily with that.
And then all that the tensor will need
to know is its bites, its shape, and the
dtype size.
Probably should just be the d type.
We'll say
that's a very easy refactor. should save
I don't know a few lines.
And then the next thing,
let's go look at our allocator because
this thing looks big, man. Like why is
it this complicated
And I did it this way.
I did it this way so I could zero some
stuff, didn't I?
It's probably just better to have three
allocators, right?
Yeah, this is a little janky the way it
is.
At least these shitty one lines here in
models are now actually reasonable.
That's defensible at the least.
Yeah, this is what we want. See all
these? Look how much better this is.
bytes.shape. Instead of this, you get
these just nice duct initializers.
That's the main thing I wanted.
And look, it actually even gets rid of
this because it realizes that this
function sucks now because you can just
do it this way.
Isn't that cool?
So, it actually just deletes this
because it realized that this thing is
[ __ ] now.
It didn't realize to do this from the
start, but once I do it, it realized,
oh, okay, we don't need this.
And that actually was specifically one
of the function I was looking at is why
the hell is this here?
So, um I guess then the question is
going to be how much code this saves and
whether anything is broken. It's trying
to build it though, so it should work.
Let's see if it works first
and then we will get the uh the line
count.
Might be at least be a little bit less,
right?
Okay,
that looks like it works.
Yep, that's the exact same results as
before.
That's actually better than I expected.
What is that? That is
like 60 lines, isn't it? 50 lines.
Yeah,
that is very, very nice.
Where did they come out of? We got 36
lines out of pufferlib.cu CU
and we got 28 lines out of the models
file.
That's nice.
That's very nice.
It is 60 lines. That's nice.
60 to four lines.
Cool.
I'm going to make a quick commit. I'm
happy with this.
Well, we're going to have to do all the
binding files at some point, right?
takes a lot of refactor.
But wait, actually what is that now?
Yeah, this will be better.
You'll only end up needing one of these.
I think you will end up saving like 20
lines.
I don't like some of this stuff, but
it's already pretty compact.
So, let's say that that's going to be
fixed on the allocator.
This is clean.
Some of this stuff's a little weird.
I'd say like,
yeah, some of this is definitely a
little weird.
At least it's defined in a weird spot.
Oh yeah, these are going to get all
removed cuz these don't need these
comments here. These just need to be
renamed.
So this is going to be another 20 lines.
Ah,
I see.
I think I just inherited this from clean
RL.
We could try it because it's just
annoying that we have to have it.
Let's see what this thing has gone and
done.
I'd want to uplad it at least on one
harder end, not just break out.
That's going to end up being the same
amount of code as no.
might be finishing stream in a second.
We are I got some client work to do with
Spencer.
We're going to finish the last couple
here though. How does one start with RL
in big 2026?
Theoretic first approach not me the
best. I have a guide for you. This is my
most asked question. So I wrote a really
really good guide for you.
So everybody kept asking. This is my
single best piece of uh educational
content.
Here you go.
Well, if you do this, you will learn RL.
If you already are a decent engineer and
have at least some relevant background,
uh you will be doing RL quite reasonably
within a few days and very reasonably
within a few weeks. And you'll basically
be able to contribute to like latest
research within a few months
if you allocate like a few solid hours
to this a day.
If you're not familiar with my
programming in ML guide, there's a more
general one that comes before that
that's very very helpful if you're like
not used to reading scientific papers
and stuff.
I'm setting a very bad example, frankly,
with what I'm doing now with the stupid
language models. Um, the amount of code
I'm letting them,
but I'm kind of stuck this way until I
at least get this codebase into a
reasonable shape.
Okay, this is this is the number that we
want.
I guess maybe it's not clear to people,
but when I say, oh, it'll save a few
lines, like
line count is not a perfect measure of
code complexity.
Um, but assuming you're not gulfing crap
and introducing more ind direction, if
you're like deleting indirection,
generally making lines the same length
or shorter and you're removing a count,
then typically you are simplifying your
code base. So, you know, there's a
certain reduction in of complexity in my
mind that is associated with going from
5,000 lines to 4,000 lines, right?
And then in my head I have like, you
know, if I get this to 4,000 lines,
that'll be reasonably lean, not too much
fat. If I get to 3,000 lines, it would
be super super lean and concise, right?
And the fat is always the confusing bit
as well. You know, like when you have
code that's doing the minimal amount of
stuff that it needs to do, uh there's
basically nothing left to confuse
anybody because like you're only doing
the operations that are obviously
required. And it's very very natural.
It's just like very very natural.
5340 lines
minus
uh was it 5340?
All right. 4481
cuz puffer net.h doesn't count. This is
for something else.
So
this is now like less than a thousand
line penalty for not using torch. And
depending on if we need orthogonal and
depending on a few other things, I think
we can definitely get this to 4K. We can
maybe even get it down to 3.5.
I will be very very happy with that.
Let's just um let's clean this up real
quick. Let's make a nice commit.
I'm probably going to be back in the
evening. I don't know if I'm going to
stream it.
Like, we'll see about that.
I might keep streaming.
and we have at least another 50 for
free.
It's all bringing us closer. I got to go
do a little bit of client work now,
guys. Um until dinner, I think. And then
depending on when I get back from
dinner, I will either stream or I will
keep working on this. But I will be
working on this either way.
Tomorrow I have some client work to do.
So, it depends on how long that takes,
whether I'll be streaming this tomorrow
or not. I will be streaming this on
Saturday as well. Uh oh, you know, I
also have a talk to prepare tomorrow.
So, I probably will not be streaming.
We'll see. Uh I have a talk that I'll be
giving on Saturday. So, it'll be like
stream a bit, give a cool talk. The talk
will be streamed as well. So, if you're
interested in just hearing more general,
more accessible stuff on my work on
neural MMO and on making complex
environments and on how we make stuff
fast, all of that in a more accessible
format, I will be giving a talk. It'll
be just broadcast here on my stream, but
it's also for university.
And
uh then the rest of the day, Saturday,
will be devoted to continuing to clean
this up.
We almost have this to the point where
we can just like start running
experiments on it. I want to make sure
everything's super super stable before
we do that. Was pretty good so far.
Um, so thank you all for tuning in. If
you want to support my work for
absolutely free, absolutely free, takes
5 seconds, just start the GitHub, like
Star Puffer on GitHub. It really, really
helps me out a lot. You'd be surprised.
Um, you know, we do have a business tied
to this and it helps companies see my
work even though it's all open source.
Uh, you can follow me on X for more
content and you can join the Discord to
get involved with dev and